his tenures tony stark may have come to
an end but the MCU has left Robert
Downey jr. with the kind of professional
resources he never had before in his
career from a massive worldwide fan base
to a hefty bank account to the kind of
clouds in Hollywood that will allow him
to pursue a host of new projects here's
why he left the MCU and what's ahead for
Marvel's first leading man
why did Downey and his fellow Avenger
Chris Evans elect to leave the MCU in
the first place Disney 23 Magazine has
the answer in a recent chat with The
Insider outlet the iconic Iron Man actor
said their time was simply up saying we
had to get off we opted to and knew it
was part of the job to get off the bus
while it rolled on to other destinations
there's something very sobering about it
I'm glad he and I will be there to
welcome others as they retire their
jerseys no amount of money ever bought a
second of time
smart guy as for his legacy in the MCU
our DJ was his usual charming and
self-effacing self saying I really don't
need to look any farther than my
co-stars Mark Ruffalo is an activist
Chris Evans is a die-hard American and
proponent of true democracy I don't
really have the gumption the skillset
the drive or the humility either of
those guys do his modesty is sweet but
MCU fans will always love our DJ 3000
and will keep their fingers crossed for
a cameo or two as the marble machine
moves on without him to major film
adaptations of Hugh loftiness Doctor
Dolittle novels have already been
released including Eddie Murphy's
famously broad take on the character
now it's Downey's turn to take on the
role of an eccentric animal expert who's
able to talk to his animal friends
Downey has been attached to the project
since the spring of 2017 and principal
photography on the film began the
following year but then the production
hit a snag in April of 2019 it was
reported that producers had serious
concerns about the initial cuts of the
film after some rewrites and much
reported tweaking the studio push back
the film's release date from the summer
of 2019
to January 17th 2020 in addition to
Downey in the title role the voyage of
dr. Doolittle will feature an all-star
cast of celebrity voices for animals
including spider-man himself Tom Holland
shortly after he began his cinematic
journey as Tony Stark Robert Downey jr.
took on another iconic character
Sherlock Holmes Downey played the
legendary detective in two action-heavy
films in 2009 and 2011 which grossed
more than 1 billion dollars worldwide
combined the Sherlock Holmes films were
directed by Guy Ritchie and packed top
tier talent into their casts including
Jude Law's dr. Watson in the spring of
2018 Warner Brothers pictures finally
announced the third film in the series
featuring the return of Downey in the
title role and law as Watson we know
very little about the bill which was
originally set to be released on
Christmas Day 2020 but has since been
pushed back to December 21st 2021 this
new date places the sequels release date
ten years after its predecessor Sherlock
Holmes a Game of Shadows the project
does not yet have an announced director
which means there's a chance Ritchie
could also return in 2017 it was
announced that Downey would star in an
upcoming film based on an episode of the
reply-all podcast the episode titled man
of the people was the story of john
brinkley a doctor who rose to fame and
fortune in the early 20th century for a
number of
strange and controversial medical
procedures including transplanting goat
testicles into humans as dramatized in
the 2016 Brinkley documentary nuts the
pioneering doc used radio as a way to
reach the masses Downey will reportedly
star in the film as Brinkley putting him
in a great position to use his charm
on-screen for a con manual Richard
Linklater will direct while Downey and
his wife Susan will produce through
their team Downey production banner the
film does not yet have a release date
Downey has great comedy chops something
we've known about him since the early
days of his career when he was playing
supporting roles in John Hughes films
like weird science he's got more recent
opportunities to show off those skills
thanks to films like chef and due date
sometime soon he'll be flexing his
comedy muscles in a big way yet again
with a role in all-star weekend the
directorial debut of his the soloist
co-star Jamie Foxx Foxx is the writer
director and star of the film which
follows two friends as they make it from
their home in Indiana to the NBA
all-star game in Los Angeles while
constantly battling each other as fans
of LeBron James and Steph Curry
respectively all-star weekend does not
have an announced release date yet and
as of late 2018 Fox was still looking
for the right distributor for the
project back in 2016 it was reported
that Downey would star in a new
miniseries from HBO following a
reimagined version of criminal defense
attorney Perry Mason from the CBS
television series starring Raymond Burr
which ran from 1957 to 1966
you didn't kill Thompson but you did mr.
Welles
set in 1930s Los Angeles the miniseries
is set to focus on the characters origin
story when the project was initially
announced true detective creator NIC
pizzolatto was also on board to write
the miniseries things have changed
significantly in the last three years
but Perry Mason is still happening
Downey is still very much involved
though he will no longer star in the
series Downey has instead stepped back
into the role of executive producer on
the series alongside his wife and
producing partner Susan Downey the
American star Matthew Rhys has instead
been cast in the title role he may be
done playing Tony Stark
but Robert Downey jr. journey as a
world-changing mogul may be just
beginning Downey appeared at Amazon's
remorse conference in June 2019 and in
the midst of a 20-minute talk about his
life career and interest in technology
and the environment he announced a major
new initiative in April of 2020 Downey
will launch the footprint coalition an
organization that will work to improve
the environment using advanced
technologies like artificial
intelligence and nanotechnology
basically Downey's playing Tony Stark in
real life he said during the
announcement between robots and
nanotechnology we could clean up the
planet significantly if not totally in
ten years at this point we still don't
know exactly what the footprint
Coalition will do first or what
technologies that we'll use to achieve
its goals at the moment the organization
is little more than a sparse website
with an option to sign up for a
newsletter but if our DJ is involved
it's likely to make plenty of headlines
in the years to come check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
MCU stars are coming soon subscribe to
our YouTube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]